je reçois maintenant gad elmaleh
daniel maghen soir bonsoir alors vous
avez déclaré gad elmaleh en ce moment je
pourrais aller à la télévision tous les
jours tellement j'ai des propositions
mais je refuse beaucoup de choses
je refuse de faire des vannes à la
chaîne ou de me mettre un poulet sur la
tête pour faire rire les gens
un pool her way up
voilà c'est que gad refuse de faire donc
c'est des vins de la chaîne et se mettre
un poulet sur la tête c'est dommage ça
vous va très bien alors le spectacle la
vie normale c'est un gros carton
vous l'avez déjà joué trois cents fois
mise en scène d'isabelle nanty et là
vous le jouez encore et moi c'est la fin
là ça va céder dernière a cédé 30
dernière une ultime et irrévocable du 14
mai au 16 juin au casino de paris seul
comment on fait gad la main rotatif la
main rotatives oui donc voila quoi après
c'est fini il faut y aller là oui il
faut y aller parce qu'après c'est fini
ce qui rompt pas on ça oui le
territorial dvd la cassette comment on
fait gaffe tu m'as rotatives